game pass you may have heard about it if
not well as a service with a lot of
games so many games it can be a little
hard to know what's worth checking out
so here's a list to give you a glimpse
into the many many games that the
service has to offer also if there
weren't already enough games to choose
from microsoft is bound to acquire
activision blizzard in 2023 meaning
game pass is about to get a whole lot
bigger check out a video to see every
major franchise and studio xbox picked
up with the 68.7 billion dollar
acquisition check out the card in the
corner
all right let's get some new ones out of
the way rainbow six extraction it's
rainbow six siege meets pve in a mutated
alien invasion extraction takes the
tactical gameplay of siege but makes it
cooperative for some newcomers siege can
have an intimidating learning curve with
its many many operators and their
distinct gear and abilities on top of
going toe to toe with other players so
extraction is a welcome change of pace
as it has a lot of what siege teaches
its players but instead just with you
and two of your friends against a wide
range of alien creatures who knows maybe
you'll play this it'll be like a gateway
into siege if you haven't gone down that
rabbit hole just yet well after all
siege is also available on game pass
here's another new one nobody saves the
world it's a dungeon crawler action rpg
where you get your hands on a magic wand
that grants you the power to change
forms like into a mouse or a horse or a
magician with each form granting you a
unique ability to maneuver through the
game's dangerous dungeons you play as
nobody like their name is actually
nobody but with this wand in essence
nobody can be everybody also gamespot's
very own steve watts gave this game a 9
out of 10 so bim bam boom
[Music]
death's door is a game that deals with
themes of death grief and morality but
despite its rather grim concepts it's
not all doom and gloom with this one it
sure got a melancholy vibe but its story
is packed with plenty of charm and jokes
that balance its tone you play as a crow
whose job is to collect souls and
honestly it's kind of a grind in a nine
to five kind of way however when an
elderly crow steals one of your souls
well you're forced to cross a land of
devoid of death to get it back you'll be
hacking slash and dodging and shooting
your way through tough bosses and some
unruly characters it's a cool spin on
the soulsborne gameplay loop made
popular by from software games but a
little more approachable it's also got
the yi ol familiar ghibli inspiration to
tout
[Music]
a legendary addition for a legendary
franchise
whether you're playing it all over again
or this is your first time the mass
effect legendary edition is mass effect
1 2 3 wrapped up and remastered so take
control of commander shepard and strap
in for galactic adventure across the
milky way set in the 22nd century where
choices matter and span across all three
games besides there's another mass
effect on the way so here's a pretty
compelling reason to explore this
bioware classic
speaking of trilogies the hitman trilogy
is now on game pass 2 become the iconic
bald guy with the barcode on the back of
his head and enter an intricate world of
assassination this is the pinnacle of
the hitman franchise and has some of the
best levels and locations to play over
and over again because getting the lay
of the locations learning the routines
of your targets and exploring the many
many ways in which you can assassinate
someone is nothing short of just
remarkable game design and this trilogy
is the shining achievement of developer
io interactive it'll also make you
realize why there's probably no better
developer suited for james bond games so
here's looking forward to whatever
they're doing with that
you know what maybe investing yourself
into a sprawling trilogy set in space or
being a cool bald agent assassin man
isn't what you're looking for maybe your
video game escapism is to become
imprisoned in school with a murderous
little bear on the loose and in order to
survive you have to murder a fellow
classmate and get away with it if that
sounds more appealing to you then well
guess what don gunrapa is exactly that
this is a visual novel adventure game
with an anime charm shaken up into a
gruesome team murder cocktail
and if you like the taste of that
cocktail consider checking something
else on their menu like ai the sumnium
files it's the same devs and just as
dark but in this game you're a detective
who enters dreams to solve puzzles and
learn clues about the gruesome murder of
a woman found on a merry-go-round in an
interesting twist you're only allowed
six minutes in every dream so every
second counts in this multiple ending
sci-fi thriller mystery you'll be
interrogating suspects investigating
crime scenes and looking cool while
doing it
now here's something a little more
calming but still brimming with mystery
and intrigue firewatch it's set in the
year 1989 you take the role of a man
named henry who took a job to patrol the
wyoming wilderness along the way you
engage in conversation with your
supervisor delilah where you unravel a
bit about yourself and her while also
trailing knee deep into a mystery amidst
the woods this game is fantastic i
haven't played it in years but the
experience the conversations the
characters and the mystery is ingrained
in my memory as one of my favorite story
experiences it offers its share of
player choice that allow you to shape
the narrative in your own unique way and
how that mystery unravels is well
something to behold
so just stay in your tower okay
stay in there
and watch
now this one isn't as narrative heavy as
the other games but instead it's a
unique and entrancing puzzle game
one that tests the player to use
perspective and image shifting to
progress through illustrated scenarios
its design is simple but the puzzles and
how the scenarios play out are quite
mind-bending and impressive it's just
very satisfying imaginative and calming
and can be a nice break in between halo
sessions or killing dudes with fire
hydrants as a bald assassin
lastly this is a game i've had a good
time with the possession to calvary it's
a point-and-click adventure made
entirely with renaissance paintings its
presentation and jokes are reminiscent
of monty python filled with plenty of
wits and fourth wall breaking antics
there's also many methods to solving
problems but not all of your solutions
may lead you down a glorious path in
that regard the game does a great job of
allowing the player to make their own
choices and explore in
several humorous ways i consider this
one a nice little hidden gem in the game
pass catalog that is well worth at least
checking out
[Music]
all right go play games and be good and
all that stuff if there's any games you
don't think get enough love on game pass
then let me know after all there's a lot
to choose from or if you're like me you
can just set aside this entire catalog
and just play wolfenstein 2 again
because
that urge is a hard one to resist
anyways keep it here gamespot for all
the game stuff bye now
[Music]